[Music]
before we start this video i want to
quickly mention that only 27
of you are subscribed if you enjoy the
content please consider subscribing to
support the channel
i've also seen some comments saying that
youtube unsubscribed them from the
channel
so please check hey everyone welcome to
another installment
of harry potter theory in today's video
we're going to be discussing a character
that you may
have heard of i am of course talking
about the primary
protagonist for the harry potter story
harry potter
himself now ever since the last book
came out
harry has been on the receiving end of a
considerable amount of scrutiny
at least from some of the internet and i
say after the last book came out because
at that stage we had a better picture of
the whole
harry potter story and everything that
harry had endured
before we dive in further let me say
this harry is a talented young wizard
however what many have criticized this
series for doing
is essentially giving harry plot armor
for those unaware
plot armor otherwise known as script
immunity
or a character shield is essentially a
term
used to describe a main character's
inability to die
the idea behind it is this the main
character is too important to the story
to be removed therefore his or her
health
life are safeguarded by plot
conveniences
to this i would say sure i get it
sometimes the plot
seems to really go out of its way to
ensure that harry stays safe
but we do have to remember that harry is
the main character
and it's hardly unreasonable for rowling
to keep the character around
that drives the story forward
furthermore while his
life health are always preserved his
preservation is also quite well thought
out
for the most part it's not just
haphazardly jotted into the story but of
convenience
traditionally books are scrutinized for
giving protagonists
plot armor when they are safeguarded by
unlikely or irregular means
things that aren't properly thought out
but i think the jk rowling
did think things out quite well one
argument for why harry's plot armor is
so
thick however the time and time again he
seems to be able to go
toe to toe with powerful dark wizards
that far exceed
his level of power after all harry
didn't even know about the wizarding
world
until it was time for him to attend
hogwarts if we look at things reasonably
how on earth could he have accomplished
some of the things that he did
without plot armor in today's video i
want to discuss
harry's level of power and the alleged
plot armor at play
examining a bunch of situations in which
out of what some may construe as plot
convenience
harry is bailed out from there you can
make your own decision
as to whether or not you feel that it's
plot armor or just
reasonable plot development was harry a
supremely powerful wizard
an untalented and extremely lucky wizard
or an above average wizard with a
considerable amount of luck
on his side first let's jump all the way
back to harry's first encounter with
adversity
his showdown with voldemort on that one
fateful day in godric's hollow
october 31st 1981 wasn't only the day
that beloved couple
lily and james potter died it was also
the day that marked the defeat of the
dark lord
for the first time and the astonishing
survival of harry
when harry finally came of age to attend
hogwarts his reputation
having survived an attack by the dark
wood himself preceded him
and this meant that he entered a world
where he already had fame
he didn't know the world of magic at all
but here he was
strolling down diagonally with everyone
thinking that he had somehow
single-handedly stopped the dark lord so
now you might be asking how did harry
survive
well it was actually his mother's doing
harry did nothing
without drilling down into it too much
baby harry was protected from voldemort
because of lily's loving sacrifice her
sacrificial protection
in harry potter it's commonly expressed
that love
trumps all other manners of powerful
magic and in this instance
that power was truly showcased in its
totality
stopping the dark lord in his tracks so
harry was saved by his mother and this
may seem awfully convenient given
that he was a baby and quite literally
unable to defend himself
against a house cat let alone one of the
most powerful dog wizards of all time
however where some may say plot armor i
simply say
plot if harry died right then and there
i'm not sure there would have been much
of a story to tell
it's established right from the
beginning that the power of love
simply trumps all and this is the first
example of the power of love
in action the next example of harry
achieving the unthinkable
comes in the form of harry stopping the
basilisk in the chamber of secrets
the basilisk is an ancient gigantic
behemoth of a creature
that is about as deadly as they come
however
harry in typical harry fashion of course
bests this creature
at the tender age of 12 with virtually
no advanced
magical capability was harry's defeat
over this beast plot armor
in my opinion not really and i say not
really because everything that
contributes to him defeating the
basilisk
seems well thought out he doesn't
outright defeat the basilisk with his
pure
raw magical power he gets help as any
protagonist does
hermione helps him with his research and
forks shows up to help harry
which makes perfect sense given that
dumbledore is practically
omniscient fawkes shows up and claws the
basilisks eyes out
and next the sorting hat provides harry
with the sword of gryffindor
a sword presented to only a true worthy
gryffindor
that allows him to defeat the basilisk
the sword thing is a little convenient
but everything else about this situation
seems reasonable
harry's next grand victories came at the
triwizard tournament
in the goblet of fire where he passed
all of the tournament's tests with
flying colours
harry didn't face much trouble in the
tournament and that's largely because he
always had a witness advantage
being given help by bharti kratch jr
throughout
however while his assistance from crouch
jr served him in the tournament
allowing him to effectively pass the
challenges it didn't come without
repercussions
it was always the intention of crouch
junior to allow
harry to win so that he would eventually
claim the triwizard cup
a secret porky and be transported to the
little hangleton graveyard
harry passed all of the tests and
overcame any sort of adversity that he
faced
but his assistance wasn't haphazardly
introduced to continue the plot
it was an integral part of the plot the
next
significant example of harry's potential
plot armor
was when he faced voldemort in the
graveyard harry grabs the pork key in
the tri-wizard maze
and is transported to little hangleton
where he is faced with voldemort and
wormtail
after taunting harry a bit and basically
explaining that his original defeat was
a fluke
voldemort and harry enter into a jewel
the beams of light lock in mid-air
the two wizards are entered into a power
struggle and
somehow harry is able to once again
fend off one of the most powerful
wizards ever
however it wasn't that harry was more
powerful than voldemort
not even close the two entered the
stalemate for a number of reasons
first of all lily's loving sacrifice was
still at play
second of all voldemort had regenerated
his body using harry's blood
and third of all the two wizards were
using brother ones
the final example of harry's plot armor
in play
is when he duels voldemort at the end of
the battle of hogwarts
at this stage harry and voldemort once
again enter
into a magical power struggle however
what's unique about this jewel in
particular
is that harry is no longer hawk rugs for
voldemort and voldemort is using a wand
to which he is not the rightful owner
the rules
surrounding the ownership of the elder
wand meant that harry was the
real owner of the wand which meant that
voldemort was not able to kill
harry with it when voldemort fires his
final avada kedavra at harry
it bounces right back at him just as it
did so many years prior
putting an end to the dark lord forever
tom riddle hit the floor with a mundane
finality
his body feeble and shrunken the white
hands empty
the snake-like face vacant and unknowing
voldemort was dead
killed by his own rebounding curse and
harry stood with two ones in his hand
staring down at his enemy's shell one of
the most
glaringly obvious issues with harry as a
protagonist is that
yes voldemort wasn't able to kill him
but that shouldn't mean
that no one can kill him however for
some reason
harry is this untouchable important
figure
that the death eaters must leave alone
being saved and groomed for voldemort to
eventually kill
himself so did harry have plot
convenience
well kind of yeah but i don't think that
his plot armor is quite as bad
as some make it out to be what do you
guys think let me know in the comment
section
below until next time it does not do
to dwell on dreams and forget to live
you